foreign
so in this I'm using the receptive blend
let's go ahead and go to this side so as
he comes in for me here I'm moving into
him and taking his Center Line and at
the same time receiving that hand so I I
control it here and back away so I'm
feeling this so I'm very receptive and
strike and at the same time taking a
Center Line taking his balance out from
under two after the other side so as he
comes in here boom I'm taking a center
line and controlling the hand from here
I slid this hand down to his thumb and
this one goes to an inside of his wrist
I stand Culp you into him already
getting him to start to turn the
kashianage I step through and come to a
strong position here I then apply this
you don't have it bring him down from
here I drive my forearm into his tricep
and pull his hand back we're getting the
beginning of a separation in his elbow
and his shoulder there's the task
one more time in speed
right
out
Yoko manuchi shihonagi